this is a guardian tradition 20 years in
change you're about to say i am the old
god yes that's right uh and my
predecessor was there for 20 years too
virtually so
that'll be three editors in 60 years
whether it likes it or not though the
guardian is a national institution known
around the world
and
has changed extraordinarily uh under
alan ross richards oh that's right
everything in the in the media world as
you know is changing in that extreme
state of digital flux
alan took over just as that was
beginning to gather speed he had to
decide as all editors have to decide
whether print newspapers are enough
whether you want to become something
entirely digital and different and he
went for free he went for free and
online and the guardian's got a great
many international followers that that's
right and and the guardian is
either the second or the third i'm not
sure this month uh biggest newspaper
website in the world i've seen as many
by a brave decision but obviously paid
off i mean what else do you think stand
out as a highlight for alan rushford
there are two things to say about allen
one is the the level of digital
engagement and engagement with the
future and trying to chart a path
through all of this it's absolutely down
to him and it's been his back
we'll know much later on whether he's
right or not but he's given it
absolutely fantastic go
and the other thing in terms of
just now this last few years is another
run of terrific stories wikileaks edward
snowden
he goes out still in possession of a
pulitzer prize this summer that looks
like a
a global sort of achievement which is
being hailed as i read my tweets all
around there and of course phone hacking
as well
which
whatever else it's done it seems to me
has created a kind of culture wars in
the british media which wasn't there
before
uh i think that to an extent is true uh
i think actually if you sit all new men
down together
singly and say was it good to expose
phone hacking do we need to know about
all this most of them individually will
agree
the actual problem is that
some of the repercussions have been
pretty harsh
people arrested on bail for an awfully
long time
uh it creates all sorts of tensions and
ironically
the state getting more involved in the
running of the media which a liberal
newspaper would never be unfair this is
this must be true yeah no i mean uh
what goes around comes around and it's
covering around with a pretty fair old
bat
and uh peter your advice for the next
editor if that is they want to hang onto
the job for 20 years what would be your
advice to them
i guess the next senator if you're
looking at the odds will be a woman a
woman
i can't well i can't promise and bear in
mind the guardian is a funny old beast
so you
a it's a sort of papal
non-election
uh yeah well that the journalists have
an indicative vote which the trust may
or may not take any notice of and it may
have changed this year because nobody's
got around to discussing so if you put
together mickelthwaite of the economist
the changes at gawker and the changes at
the garden is this basically old media
feeling the heat
uh
up to a point lord copper but it's it's
it's also people saying editing things
these days is an extraordinary strenuous
difficult job
and it may be time to go and do
something a bit quieter peter preston
thank you very much